c'est une faveur que nous lui faisons tu
nettoieras les salles de répétition et
les salles de représentation quand tu
auras des pauses et tu ne distriras sous
aucun prétexte mes élèves pour les
empêcher de réaliser leur objectif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu as repris la danse
tu m'avais caché que tu étais si doué
non c'était rien madame arlo a gardé
cette chambre libre elle devait savoir
qu'un jour ou l'autre tu reviendrais
[Musique]
la danse elle doit se ressentir on la
regarde pas Arlo veut retrouver son
étoile mais arrête encore
arrête je sais même pas si je sais
encore danser
ta soeur elle elle aurait mis son âme à
nu je suis pas bien
[Musique]
alors montre moi qui tu es
plus grands interprètes les artistes
partage tout ça profond désir de
raconter une histoire
et d'une certaine manière
il y aura toujours une part
de leur propre histoire c'est drôlement
tout ça
[Musique]
tu as traversé un terrible taille
ce n'est pas la seule histoire que tu as
raconté
il est temps pour toi de raconter ton
histoire Sam
[Musique]